[Music]
welcome everybody to Long crime daily
I'm Jesse Weber some say she's a witness
others say she's the shooter well the
woman whose testimony could be pivotal
in an assault case involving A-list
celebrities took the stand again on
Thursday Kelsey Harris arrived at an LA
Courthouse Thursday morning to continue
her testimony about the night rapper
Megan the stallion was shot in the foot
Harris former best friend and assistant
to Megan was at a get-together at Kylie
Jenner's house along with Megan and
rapper Tory Lanez there was an argument
as the three were getting in a car to
leave and Megan got out and she
testified that she was walking away when
Lanes told her to dance and shot toward
her feet Lane says though he's innocent
and that he's being set up the judge
isn't allowing any Electronics in the
courtroom but the good news is long
crime senior reporter Megan cuniff has
been taking very detailed notes and
bringing us what she saw and heard
during testimony
so she was testifying but while she was
testifying she wanted to plead the fifth
to when she was asked about Tori
threatening to shoot her in the car
before the car stopped and Megan got out
and was shot and she really didn't want
to answer that question she did confirm
that Tori did threaten to shoot her but
when uh the prosecutor asked what he
said she asked if she could uh plead the
fifth and they said no that she can't
and uh that was just really hard for her
you could tell she really struggled with
saying anything incriminating about Tori
or just or just trying to say anything
about him in any way but the prosecutor
really over a kind of painful couple
hours tried to kind of press her about
the fact that she was very candid about
this back in September in a recorded
interview that of course they were able
to play for the jury and she sounds a
lot more candid about the shooting and
she's talking about how she she saw Tori
doing the shooting
she wouldn't get into that on the stand
co-host legal analyst former trial
Attorney Terry Austin's here with me now
Terry most people have heard of pleading
the fifth but there is a lot more that
goes into it than I just don't want to
talk right well exactly Jesse I mean the
Fifth Amendment provides the right to
remain silent it says no person shall be
compelled in any quote criminal case to
be a witness against himself but like
all laws the Fifth Amendment is subject
to interpretation by the courts and the
Supreme Court has expanded the right to
remain silent to include interrogations
depositions civil proceedings so the
setting doesn't affect the availability
of the privilege as long as there is a
threat of criminal liability now Jesse
get this that doesn't mean you can
arbitrarily refuse to testify the case
law also states that the threat of
future criminal prosecution must be
quote reasonable and appreciable so in a
trial setting that means the judge will
determine whether you can assert the
privilege if the judge agrees that
there's a real threat of future
prosecution then and you can remain
silent but if the judge says no Then you
could be compelled to testify and if you
refuse you could be held in contempt so
there's a lot to consider there is you
know Terry thanks for breaking that down
I think it's important for everybody to
understand but I should tell you during
her testimony Harris told the Los
Angeles County Deputy district attorney
that there were things she wasn't
entirely truthful about in the recorded
interview she testified that she has
moved on with her life but that Megan
spread rumors about her taking hush
money something that she denies that she
denies ever being paid off and she
rebutted all attempts by the D.A to
press her into saying that Tori she saw
Tory Lanez shoot Megan I'm here with
co-host and public defender Brian
buckmeyer as well I want to get your
input on this so this trial really took
a turn when Kelsey Harris got on the
stand right yeah Jesse Kelsey Harris was
supposed to be the prosecution star
witness and she was anything but her
testimony left people speculating when
she paid off she testified to Tory Lanez
offering her a million dollars for a
lawyer but then she pled the fifth when
asked if Tory Lanez threatened her but
how would that answer incriminate her
unless it bleeds into what she did in
response so the question becomes what
did Kelsey say or do in response to
being threatened by Tory Lanez add on
top of that she said that she told
investigators back in September
statements that were the Bedrock of the
prosecution's opening statements were
now false but at the end of the day in
this criminal case it only matters what
these 12 jurors think and so far I can't
imagine they're all on the same page and
if they are that spell and sorry if
they're not that spells reasonable doubt
that may lead to a hung jury or not
guilty I don't know if Tory Lanez is
innocent or not but that's not what the
jury is deciding is deciding if the
prosecution has proven their case Beyond
A Reasonable Doubt and that after Kelsey
Harris's testimony I'm not sure here's a
prediction I think at the end of this
we'll still not know exactly what
happened that day that's my prediction
Brian great explanation thank you so
much